Ticketmaster Auto look in the mirror and
say
I'm the problem it's me I have to throw
out in deference to my daughter Eliza
one one more Taylor Swift quote karma's
a relaxing thought aren't you envious
that for you it's not Senators blame
Ticketmaster for botching a pre-sale
rollout last year for the pop stars
upcoming tour the way your company
handled
the ticket sales from the Swift
was a debacle the president of Live
Nation entertainment which operates
Ticketmaster told the Senate Judiciary
Committee the concert promoter
anticipated high demand but computerized
Bots attacked their system the attack
requires to slow down and even pause our
sales
this is what led to a terrible consumer
experience
which we deeply regret as a Ode to
Taylor Swift I will say we know all too
well